Star Wars fans probably already know
this today is May 4th or as its
otherwise known Star Wars day you know
May 4th may the 4th be with you oh yeah
this is not this is sad that you think
I'm making this up and it is a joke it's
not May 4th is Star Wars day and we got
thinking today tomorrow is also an
important holiday Cinco de Mayo which
commemorates Mexico's victory so we got
we got Star Wars day today we got Cinco
de Mayo tomorrow now since we are not
taping a show tomorrow we wanted to find
a way to celebrate both holidays today
at the same time so we started trying to
come up with characters that would
combine both Star Wars and Cinco de Mayo
now originally we wanted to do a
character named obi-wan Kenobi but we
did some research and it's already been
done ok that's been done already yeah
then we tried one solo also been done
that's been done before so we tried Han
salsa okay that that'd be good
been done yeah then we thought of K so
d2 right done already done then we
thought chimichanga bakka been done okay
then we thought charged our beans okay
already done we thought Admiral Akbar a
toe that's been done then someone said
Bibb frittata been done okay
we even tried to lando calrissian beans
it's been done they've all been done
finally we found one character that no
one's ever done before so here right now
celebrating may the fourth and Cinco
DeMayo please welcome Darth Maul a
[Applause]
there is he's he's handing out
sure little lightsabers
sheral lightsabers for everybody enjoy
your life
start slowly let's get going that's
enough
[Applause]
fantastic Thank You dark hallway
everybody
fantastic Curro Curro lightsaber here
for everybody what an exciting show we
have tonight thank you sir please stay
with me I enjoy this star hmm that's
disgusting
you